let's now hear from the most
important people as far as the david
pakman show is concerned
it's the viewers it's the listeners it's
the trolls and the haters and all of
those people
we use discord for our new phone system
you can
join at davidpakman.com slash
discord let's start today
with cody from san diego cody you are on
the air
what is going on
cody please unmute yourself we don't
want to start on such a sour note you
were on the air
cody from san diego
and the last opportunity for cody from
san diego
that's too bad that's not an auspicious
start i have to tell you
let's go next to tamesha from new york
to misha from new york
please save us hi hi how are you
i'm good how are you doing well so first
of all i want to say i liked your live
stream today
talking about women as a working mother
it was really good
they know that they're actually talking
about it and thinking about it right
um but my gripe today is with black
conservatives
okay um not necessarily it's it
fits with all conservatives but um
candice owen has been in the scene
lately
talking and she just says things about
um people of color that just don't make
sense to me
i'm mixed so and she says things that
she sees herself like she um represents
herself and oh my experience is this
so this means that that's the experience
for everyone and i
wholly disagree with her that you can't
base your experience on what
affects other people or what happens to
other people yeah you don't make policy
around anecdotes you make policy around
statistics
exactly like she said about um
meghan markle that she can't possibly
have experienced
racism or colorism because she never
experienced it
herself because she was she's married to
a british guy and she never experienced
herself so how can
so she thinks meghan markle's lying
candace owens is married to a british
guy you're saying
yes oh i didn't know that that's funny i
mean isn't candace so didn't candace
owens grow up like in a privileged
connecticut suburb or something like
that i don't know much about her but it
seems like
i mean whatever her experience is may be
relevant to her but as you're pointing
out it doesn't mean it's relevant to
anybody else exactly i've seen her in
videos saying
well i i grew up poor but i overcame i
worked hard i got where i needed to be
oh okay maybe she did maybe she did i
mean i don't i don't know her story
it's just sort of like who cares what
her story is you know
exactly it's like i grew up not
privileged but i grew up
okay and i do um attribute the fact that
i do have certain privileges that other
people
i'm a lighter skinned bi-racial person
so i
definitely know i have privileges that
maybe a darker-skinned black person
wouldn't have
right so but that doesn't mean that i
can't understand that other people have
experiences that i may not experience
yeah i mean tamesha it would be sort of
like if i said hey listen
i i am a husband me david pakman i'm a
hispanic immigrant from argentina
i came to the u.s i wasn't discriminated
against
and everything's fine so clearly there's
no problem here and it's like well hold
on a second
i i'm white hispanic and i learned
english
young enough where you can't tell when
you hear me speak that i'm an immigrant
it's like what
imagine if i applied my experience and
said this is how we should think about
hispanic immigration it would be it
would be ridiculous exactly and i see
that happening so much on the right yeah
where they apply
their own experience to the rest of the
world i can't talk i'm from new york i
can't talk about what happens in middle
america
they their experience is not going to be
the same as my experience
right right and it just frustrates me
yeah well you know this this is on both
sides with the right you have these
right-wing
like social conservatives who are
homophobic for their whole lives
and then suddenly like their kid or
their nephew is gay or something and
they have like an awakening where they
can't
imagine what it's like they can't
empathize and then also
you have what you're describing which is
they believe that their situation is
everyone's situation
um it's uh yeah it's the inability to
think abstractly it's only concrete
thinking that they're able to do
exactly i was told by somebody on social
media that i went to high school with
that
i'm privileged how can i talk about this
and i'm like i'm not talking about
necessarily myself i'm talking about us
as human
people right right tamesha
beautiful phone call i really appreciate
it thank you
all right there's tamisha from new york